so i'm curious as to what happens if i
were to take a rational number and i
were to add it to an irrational number
and i were to add it to an irrational
number is the resulting number going to
be
rational or
irrational well to think about this
let's just assume it's going to be
rational and then see if we lead to if
this leads to any form of contradiction
so let's assume that this is going to
give us
a rational
a rational number
so let's say that this first rational
number we can represent as the ratio of
two integers a and b
let's call this irrational number let's
just call this
x
and let's call and their sum gives us
another rational number well let's give
make let's express that as a ratio of
two other integers m
and n
so we're saying that a over b
a over b
plus x plus x is equal to m over n
is equal to m over n well another way of
thinking about it we could subtract a
over b from both sides and we would get
our irrational number x is equal to
m over n
minus a over b
minus
a over b which is the same thing as
n times b in the denominator
n
times b and then let's see m over n is
the same thing as m b over n b so this
would be m b
i'm just adding these two fractions m
b
m b
minus minus let's see a over b is the
same thing as
n times a over n times b so minus n
times a
minus n
times
n times a all i did is i added these two
fractions i found a common denominator
so let me make it clear i multiplied
this one b
and b and then i multiplied this one n
and n and i just added these two things
and i got this expression right over
here
so this denominator is clearly an
integer i have the product of two
integers that's going to be an integer
that's going to be an integer
and then this numerator m b is an
integer and a is an integer the
difference of two integers this whole
thing is going to be an integer this
whole thing is going to be an integer
so it looks like
assuming that the sum is rational that
all of a sudden we have this
contradiction we assumed that x is
irrational we're assuming x is
irrational but all of a sudden because
we made that assumption we're able to
assume that we can represent it as the
ratio of two integers so this tells us
that x must be rational
must be
rational and that is the contradiction
that is a very large contradiction right
over there the assumption was that x is
irrational now we got that x must be
rational so therefore this cannot be the
case a rational plus an irrational must
so this is not right a rational plus an
irrational must be irrational let me
write that down just so
a rational
plus
an irrational
irrational must be
must be
irrational